moving you grooving it something
churches have them only doing an Irish
today we've got a few fans in Ireland I
would butcher an Irish accent why
extension I do think am i doing American
accent alright fried a whole episode
people this is gonna lose us about 300
subscribers alright alright
hello there my mateys this is s and g37
welcome back for dreams and foo has
rendition I can't do an American accent
something you cannot do American accent
well I can but I don't really I don't
think I could do on cue you know speak
I'm half Irish I can't do an accent to
save my life it's it sounds Irish was it
you don't see you don't see oh it sounds
Irish right let's open up the sing man
um talk to me so guys as usual like
subscribe comment subscribe to us on
patreon follow us on Instagram Twitter
all the links are in the description and
jump on the merch sng merch is live so
again link in description and your man
get your [ __ ] your [ __ ] [ __ ]
but bro dogs me this is this is funny
have you ever eaten [ __ ] so you're
eating [ __ ] you're eatin [ __ ] you're
actively eating possessive and have you
ever not stopped but have you ever
thought in the back of your mind how do
I look
from a third person
you're naked your ask naked and you're
eating gosh and your back is arched
because there's only about three ways
you can eat [ __ ] yes you can either eat
[ __ ] with them sat on your face yes
which is that's the best way the best
way for a man is the best way yeah yeah
to hold your dick knees yes she sat on
your face / 69 yes that's the best way
hmm the most common way obviously her
legs spread and you're going down there
and like on the bed and your baby's
arched your asses oh your coccyx is just
inverted and your legs you're on your
knees and your friend went especially if
they've got a footer to the bed so if it
just mattress your legs just hang on oh
yeah yeah baby it's got the thing but
like a foot board or whatever your
squeal squish so you just have to arch
more bro-bro it's embarrassing thought
about that and you probably got sweat
trickling down your back
you just look prime foot for prime to
take a dick and the thing is if you
watch porn and any free something that's
the scenario person are the guys back
shirt from the back one of those legs
and I was boozie boozie yeah
oh my word I was thinking about it the
last time I [ __ ] that's exactly what I
had in my head that's exactly what I had
in my life and then I ended up sorry I
was in the position and I was so
paranoid yeah I had to and there was a
foot there was a foot board there yeah I
had to just kind of lay down on my side
yeah and just get my legs off the side
of the bed yeah no kind of bananas yeah
well I'm just there grabbing legs that
you don't know like yeah sort of like a
[ __ ] but look the reason I always clock
myself when I clock them looking at me
that's how I clock bra looking they're
looking down
removing your grooving in it you fin
your buff your groovin your your cheeks
are just sway it your hips are just na
no how about we not laugh how do we may
not laugh
that's maybe so hard that's maybe so how
do they not laugh I don't think again
into you for it when they get lost in a
moment happen you don't think about
anything like as soon as you bus you're
not I don't want anyone looking at my
dick Omaha yeah you know I mean yeah
yeah but when we're in the moment I
don't give a [ __ ] bro that's the thing
as well and like I've only just deep to
me now mm same thing third person the
best-case scenario is that you she's
sitting on your face right mmm
at same time if you're naked mmm your
dick is just just sit there up your dick
is just solid so it has to be a sixty
diamond cut and dick and it's just there
so someone walks in and they're looking
up at the top you know I swear yeah and
then it's just a dick there's a lonely
dick just rock solid
get in there love so it have to be the
best answer is 69
oh yeah I hate 69 hardly 60 I hate 16 I
don't hate it but I just hardly do it I
don't hate it I hate it because I have a
reason why hates about I hate it because
like you don't want to say no I have a
really I don't hate it but there aren't
I have negative views of it all right
and I'll explain why after you this I've
never had a 69 where teeth didn't get
involved okay from her side okay and if
I'm doing 69 I may as well eat us
because my nose is all up in anus yeah
that's to be fair that's the sound that
is a downside so if I don't like you
enough to eat us and that's likely it's
like I don't like you enough to eat us
then I might want to do 69 yeah true
very true very true what was it the
reason you don't lie 69 yes so one of
the reasons what the main reason what
from I completely forgot about that
I'll be along your nose by the way
completely completely
infrequent I do 69 I haven't done in
years I do not like it [ __ ] out but
what I hate about 69 not hate but like
what is a downside for me I don't know
about I can't speak for all guys but for
me when you're obviously eating the
mouth
mm-hm and then they start sucking you
off mm-hmm but when her sucking me off
isn't distracting me from eating her out
but me in a route is distracted her from
sucking me off and it's like women are
so selfish when it comes to 69 I've
never bored out because I don't think
that I've never bored I was so [ __ ]
true they're always stopping - Oh big
man
suck my dick back to a saw my daughter
is aching for you do your ting do you
play your role how dare you how dare you
women are so selfish into six singers
literally her sucking my dick is not
distracting me from me in a row if
anything is making me want to do it more
do you know I mean but you have the gold
the audacity to just often say oh yeah
oh if you need too much just do it
whilst you do this once you're there
also if you're sucking dick this is for
the ladies by the way if you're sucking
dick and your hands if you if you use
your hand sucking dick and your hands
are messy you might as well be licking a
lollipop
I won't go behan I want you to look like
you've just vomited you're exactly what
I mean in a bum I wouldn't need to be a
steak just an absolute no what's the bus
minor I want to look at you like you're
[ __ ] not your [ __ ] you know his
horrible ways true its horrable with a
moment i need all in the mug I need
everything I need everything to be
didn't to be nasty
I don't want pretty head yeah no no he
wants pretty head pretty head his [ __ ]
no one wants pretty head so late for the
ladies that I give him pretty head
listen to me a man doesn't want it your
man wants disgraceful head nasty
perfect example to transition into [ __ ]
that's funny maybe ha perfect example to
transition into what would you do cuz
obviously I always say like would you do
this for this hmm what would you do to
suck a dick oh Jesus to have to suck a
dick what do you mean what would you do
so would you suck a dick tell me three
things that you would actually suck a
dick what to get that's what I mean
ah okay if I suck at it I'll get
something if you suck dick you'd get
something you have to choose the three
things that means that half this like a
dick yeah that's the point you have to
suck the dick oh I mean I think I've
been put in that position I would [ __ ]
and I hate the fact that whatever first
I would suck I don't want to say it do
you know senator Zell Simmons makes me
shiver all my days okay I'll do you know
what for to save my mom's life
okay like if she was that if those guns
met Rob I say I'll do that I say my mom
my family mmm I'm like it could be
anyone in my family but more like more
like my mom three things
I think some some form or some aspect of
Finance or money but I don't know what
this has to be a scenario Jan I mean
yeah I can't think of my own scenario
cuz I'll make this a very easy for
myself I have to be put in a situation
that's why right if my mom was example
like like died you know ever there was a
gun to her head I would I would do that
alright cool fair enough then let me
flip it would to cure would you suck two
dicks simultaneously to cure the world
of coronavirus forever that's from the
video I saw you them sent you the other
day it simultaneously simultaneously my
jaw break so you just have to go like
that bang bang so well you have to you
they they have endgame they have to not
there they have to know so you're you're
you don't want to be there yeah you're
actively trying to you you need them to
not as fast as possible so let me see
come in as hard as you're going ham in
this hands and mouth hands and mouth but
the trick is they have to come at the
same time so you can't just sort one
Johnny and then go straight to Dexter
you they need to come at the same time
in your gob or on your face and you can
use hands and mouth to get get them off
would you do it to save the world or
coronavirus it's a tough one it's a
tough one because if I say no wait does
anyone know if I if I don't do it does
anyone know that this could have been
the cause to save Corona only people oh
so like 2,000 people if not more
yes few thousand actually know what my
talk about wait wait if we're talking
the audio wave Weimer never know isn't
that [ __ ]
I would say okay I'll say why I would do
it I'm saying I wouldn't do it but
doesn't answer if you do or not for a
while I need to know if you're gonna do
it or not yeah but like all right I'm
gonna do it I've got I would I would do
it because one obviously it's I'll
probably be a national hero kind of
thing world hero friend I'll be like a
world hero and I feel like billions of
people will benefit from it and I feel
like it's the it will be the humane
thing to do part right here even though
it's very inhumane in that position in
the first place what position do I have
to be in for that to even happen
whatever is easiest for you no no no I'm
not I'm not asking you but I'm saying
like I want my obit how have I gotten
there
I'm not the figures I'm actually not ask
you I'm like all right thinking to
myself because I was gonna come up with
something I know you live in diamond
tonight then attention that's not yeah
and obviously I wouldn't do because I
don't want to suck a dick anyway so
that's the reason I wouldn't do but I
think a long story short I don't I think
right now right now I'd say yes probably
cause it's a moral thing to do but if
you actually put two dicks in front of
me do you say now I probably say no you
say let them die now let them die no
don't say that don't say that these are
the views of your own not mine
don't say that don't say that it's not
even funny don't say that the morality
of it will make me say it'll make me
want to say yes but if I saw two
rock-hard cocaine dicks there and they
said all right go right go I couldn't do
it that's why I said it's a yes-or-no
thing cuz I'd want to do it we could
look for the morality of their bike I
don't think that physically they could
do it wild
I'll do it
I will do it that old man at a hundred
percent if for Humanity Rd above for no
more Cove in nineteen ever I will suck
them off I will hate every second of it
are you sure fam you know what's funny
this is disgusting but I'm just gonna
[ __ ] we're already in deep you know
what's funny
obviously we're competitive guys in it
you can bet like you just in nature
we're competitive guys we can barely I
guess is horrific we compared guys hmm
so when obviously when I'm thinking I
need this over as far as possible yes
obviously you know when you're like
you're having sex or like your fingering
or an ass or [ __ ] going down on
someone and they give you a hint
yesterday you're doing the right thing
and you think okay we're getting there
obviously if I'm eating [ __ ] I'm doing
it so that she comes yeah so um it's a
it's a feedback thing yeah yeah if I
know we're going in the right direction
i'ma stay there i'ma stay there yeah can
you imagine for whatever's they say it's
not for the kovat thing anyway whatever
scenario this it's a billion for you
obviously you're doing I don't need to
have conversation for you it's all I
don't need to put you in that position I
know we both know everyone knows if
someone offers you a billion quid just
what these guys off you're doing it all
right this is just jump that so
obviously why you're suck knees man off
you've got if you want to get out of
there fast enough if you need to listen
out so obviously you're going you're
doing the twisty wrists and your Slurpee
slurping and then Tommy over here Tommy
over here just gives you a thrust and he
hits your throat back but when he does
it he gives it up yeah he gives it a
swallow spit
you swallow your pride and you just you
have to do it you have to do it oh ah
that's so awful that's funny that's
funny
how dreadful imagine I could never
imagine that's funny though have you
ever used the massage trick to get [ __ ]
Oh like offering to give them a massage
so I gave him a massage so I can [ __ ]
them yeah it's a tough one because
obviously I don't know if I've used it
to get I don't think I've ever used it
to get [ __ ] yeah I have got [ __ ] from
it yeah but the people don't like we
boof we both know I was only doing that
so we could fart yeah look we'd [ __ ] a
million times before they were only say
well there was never a first instance
where you just it was never like a oh
let's do the massage thing to move from
B to C they he was always like obey give
me massage and then I'm like ah his bras
in the way much and then just clip that
off and then we're just gonna [ __ ] like
he's never been like aren't you fancy
fancy a rubdown I'm assuming you have
twice it's happened to me but twice they
weren't I didn't instigate it I I wasn't
the one that said oh I'll give you a
massage and then it could obviously it
could lead to sex so the first time it
happened this was years ago years ago
this before I moved to Manchester mmm so
yeah we're talking years I was I started
Lincoln ago went on a couple dates never
had sex obviously kiss the waiver but
she lived in a send of nowhere so he's
had to drive to link up hmm and then
there was a time where we were I think
we're gonna going to watch a film but it
wasn't till about let's say for example
8 o'clock and it was probably like 5
o'clock we were chillin chillin chillin
talkin she said to me I got a wish there
boy a long story short she asked me for
a massage and I was like yeah
um I think she spoke about earlier in a
day maybe she wants a massage table I'm
like okay cool so I think I then brought
it up again whilst we were there Chilean
yeah
would you like to would you like me to
give you that massage my kind of thing
so she obviously instigated it because
she knew what it could potentially lead
to yeah I just found it through you know
I mean so she was like yeah of course
she went to get changed and came back
she was wearing a two-piece matching
lingerie weave like the silk dressing a
thin silk dressing gown and a tease one
yeah yeah and I was like yeah you women
know what you're doing cars like just
say you what a [ __ ] borough because I am
more likely to not dance around the idea
of should I rub your [ __ ] or not
yeah yeah the massage yeah yeah because
the massage could potentially just be a
massage might genuinely just want a
massage
do you know aim true so it's like do you
risk that obviously you can see she's
down yeah yeah what she no there's not
been that locker there's not been a ball
there's not a verbal agreement there's
no contract yeah and I first you gonna
massage me and then you're gonna fast me
no I mean yeah so it's it's still a
great area cool
and it's obviously I [ __ ] her Bragg's
but it's not the point it's not you know
I mean I was thinking about this you
know this is very interesting I was
thinking about this the other day like
it's so it's so attractive to me and I
know it's tragic to you because you
spoke about before is very attractive to
me for a girl to be forward mm-hm and
say like I either I just want to [ __ ] or
make the first move and just like grab a
handful of dick or just just like jump
or man or whatever like that like stuff
where that turns me the [ __ ] on like I
don't want to just be the instigator all
the time yeah do not I mean yeah like I
like it
if a girl makes the first move yeah
whether it's the first time we've or the
99th time with her like I like stuff
like that
and I've no issue being instigator but
it's something I'm just saying like
stuff like that turns me on yeah but I'm
also thinking what
did turn me on as much if that's just
how [ __ ] was because obviously we took
all the time I wish women will just
[ __ ] just say it just say it to say
would it still turn me on if women only
did that no of course not I got only
imagine imagine and then sometimes and
then I thought but deeper for maybe this
is what's like to be a girl cuz imagine
every time you just met a new girl you
were just chilling and then she just
grabbed some dick and that happens every
time
mm every [ __ ] time and then you date
for a little while and then every single
time you see her for the first three
months she's grabbing [ __ ] dick and
she's like sharp and [ __ ] me like all
the things that we wish women would say
more of it they only say that every
single time but I'll be done' grab some
dinner so that yeah as soon as you get
in the car shut up and [ __ ] me [ __ ] me
in the backseat now like every single
time you feel used in it you [ __ ] sake
every time you're watching a movie she
grab some dick every time you trying to
cook some dinner she doesn't reach
around grab some dick not when I'm
watching a movie listen to me cuz I hate
watching stuff and I'm like external
voices watching The Ting fans will watch
it or not play people need to learn you
read the room
same thing with Netflix if I put Netflix
on pit if I put Toy Story 3 on we can
[ __ ] fam if I put Minority Report on
yeah shut up shut the [ __ ] up watching a
movie
oh poor me because I'm multitasking here
yeah brother I'm reading a subtitles and
I'm watching it mmm don't add a third
party to it I read the room team that's
so not every not every Netflix session
is inefficient chilsen nah cuz I want to
watch the movie bro I want to pay
attention I don't [ __ ] about what that
man but ya know I'd [ __ ] hate it if
back to your back to your scenario I
don't [ __ ] hate that moment I mean
that's how women feel it's certainly
sexually with certain sexually
aggressive dudes
probably probably
it's a shame man it is a shame and I
don't really know what to say about it
because what I'm not in though I'm not
as a joke because I'm not in that in
there in any of their shoes my shoes or
am I not mean so I can never imagine
what they must think every time they see
their husband consider in every time
they see husband the husband was the
Banger yes she could be down but within
the same breath she would have known
that from three weeks into meeting this
man hmm so if they're married answers
given all right then she must be happy
with it unless she's been manipulated
like in a sense of emotional
manipulation but her blood liable you
will find anyone else and then she gets
like a lot of women stay with men for
the wrong reasons and that could be one
of the reasons it's true man I've got
dark yeah when I think about the other
day and I was thinking obviously yeah I
find it attractive for women to do that
but yes they did it all the time I think
my style
gee I'm an [ __ ] do you know why that
potentially could be life because if I
if I know if we live in a world where
that happens like that consistently
happens every woman is like that mm-hmm
I wouldn't get married you couldn't I
could because I would probably be
linking chicks month by month by month
by month by month by month by month I
remember why I brought this up in the
first place Carrie I'm sorry that that
was the poor there was a yeah you you're
you're a short it's a guarantee that
next month June July whatever you're
meeting another thing and they're gonna
wanna [ __ ] you if that's a guarantee
yeah I mean you just wave from the
crappy dick you litters way in
you just way in scrap that's how women
are sometimes as well that's now that's
just pops in my head that's actually how
women are
how experimental obviously we've spoken
to people we're like they're like broth
and they talk they're like a woman we
talk to us and the same rough
there we were in his room he [ __ ] yes
I've been there bro I've been that is he
might do [ __ ] he didn't do [ __ ]
no sometimes I mean exactly that so if
the woman grabbed you dick every single
time you do base that on whether she
likes you or not yeah so you'll be there
cheating in a room and she didn't grab
your dick you'd be like what the [ __ ]
like why am I even here she doesn't like
me like I was laying in your bed just
like a woman says he I was Amy but you
didn't do [ __ ] by what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you that's mad actually just come
to my head days Wow but yes say what you
were the reason obviously in the first
place is because I was listen to Drake
the other day mm-hmm and I wish I were
done the lyric I can't remember what he
said it I can't remember I delete you
can't remember but I remember listening
to it thinking rah basically I feel like
it was the new one okay but it might not
have been okay but basically he was
talking about was talking over but I
remember what he was talking about by
coming for what he used but basically he
was saying about figuring out which
woman is down yeah he said something
about she could be your wife I don't
know kind of thing like I'm just flying
true sending messages girls are trying
to [ __ ] or pie in she could be a wife I
don't even know it is Chicago freestyle
I think is Chacon I think you I thought
was Chicago freeze freeze though but it
made me think like when he said a bother
she could be the watch she could be a
wife are you spending money and blah
blah blah she could be the wife I don't
know saying like that yeah it made me
think it made me think like I wonder how
many people thinking when when to say
when's one of them so it made me think
like being that level of celebrity must
be tough to find a woman woman cuz
there's always the concept of art does
she want me from what me for my money is
intra cetera but there's also the topic
of your novelty dick hmm so there might
be clamoring to [ __ ] you they [ __ ]
you fly out you fly back into town next
time you message them and they're like
oh now I've got like a husband of got
kids I've got like like no it's not ting
like that I just want to [ __ ] Drake yeah
I wonder how like he's just the novelty
yeah yeah he's just like a dick that
they can tell someone about they're
really not fussed about him because I
was thinking about it and then it made
me think about rod like I wonder if
that's how I would be if I got it like
if you have got the chance to [ __ ] a
celebrity mm-hmm
obviously the celebrities that we spoke
about like York I Genesis later you'll
fly it's a different country to try and
sort panda yeah but there might be just
like a an ad-hoc one yeah like a [ __ ]
I can't even think it I don't want to
disrespect anyone but there could be
just like a you know just a one-off
celebrity the opportunity I know what
you mean yeah this person
yeah like this bean list I could [ __ ]
these girls and then you smash him and
you know right and you're thinking she's
done you the favor
mmm and then you go back to nominal
living a normal life but then she
actually hits you up like oh you wanna
grab some dinner
back in town you're like you'd be
thinking what univer laughs was just
thank you mom yeah as begin obviously
guys got male celebrities of that
caliber must get that constantly incas
constantly because yes there's ones i
want you for you but you gotta navigate
through the ones that wanna secure a
relationship yeah but did they just want
me for my money
yeah and my status and do they want me
for the life that they can put attention
live by having a relationship with me
and there's the ones that you hang out
with you like you [ __ ] you get back in
contact and turns out that they just
wanted you for the novelty for that they
just want you for drake and then one day
for gram or all be sorry they didn't
want you for Bri they wanted you for
Drake and that's it then then words are
carrying all their life interesting
right he's enjoy it happens though it
does and I feel like a lot of that's why
a lot of young rappers in my opinion
have a lot of baby moms I think that's
one of the reasons because they get so
caught up into the
lifestyle of everything being thrown at
them like they're in the media they've
got money
women are frantically they could be the
ugliest person in the world enough like
Jay Haas for example he calls himself
he's Instagram his life ugly Graham ugly
grammar something yeah he's been calling
himself ugly since before he had like
money money
mmm-hmm and it's crazy because he's
exactly the same person but he does look
ten times more handsome now of course
bro money gross is everything and it
baffles me because when he was making
that dem boy pagan in there if you look
at him you'd think no one's obviously
gonna wanna [ __ ] you can't say you know
I mean but in my opinion he is the
hardest rapper in the UK in my opinion I
[ __ ] love Jay house when I was like
when I see stuff like Instagram stuff
has got a clothing line and everything
when I see him now when he like in music
videos and stuff I think I'm not even
music videos like GQ cut like all these
stuff ya know even graphs of stuff
thinking Rogers dudes I should pretty
handsome mm-hmm and he calls himself
he's been cutting this off ugly for time
mm-hmm
money does and he's the same bread ah
like he obviously is not had any like
plastic surgeries made red dot broke
money changes but he likes it he looks
ten times better than he did
changes everything it's mind-blowing
everything it's mad like mind-blowing
it doesn't it doesn't make any sense it
doesn't make any sense but it's just a
fact like and it's a fact that is we
don't that men can acknowledge it as
well mmm for other men like men can
acknowledge you for other men oh you're
categorically bet like you're more
handsome now yeah as a dude like just
you got [ __ ] money in you're more
handsome yeah that made no sense it
doesn't it doesn't make [ __ ] liquor
sense I mean I wouldn't complain oh I
definitely wanna go blow but definitely
one good blood hey ho G hey her it's the
way the world on I was gonna also time
imagine [ __ ] I imagine being like
this is a completely off topic
imagine being a
magic so like gluten and dairy and
downswings they're like first of all I
think I am allergic to dairy and as
anyone is egg baby that's long like
cereal pasta milk cheese ice cream like
fam long I'll be healthy if I was though
if I was allergic to gluten I'll be
healthy
I'd be shredded all year round I wish I
was alleged to glue no you don't
I took be fatter I am definitely
allergic to dairy I am definitely
learning today from Syria which says if
I have a bowl of just cereal my battles
murder my [ __ ] is poor pin fam you
already know me when it comes to my
digestive system anyway I've got the
worst digestive system in the world
Dairy makes me far from ice cream bro
I'm any full of discontent have ice
cream any form of dessert is ruining but
you never used to do that and that I
never used to have an issue of dairy
just so weird until I was doing a
physique competition
my last physique competition I was I
didn't have dairy for months I don't
even like knowing I'm sorry
this one was in and I were not on me was
[ __ ] where was this one I want to say
berming now I wasn't blaming him it was
somewhere I don't [ __ ] remember where
it was bait was somewhere but it might
be like lement inspire or something
random like that but anyway denim ended
day for like three months
not a drop yeah as soon as I finished
the show smashed dairy ice cream cereal
cheese order fam I was blow it blow it
and I fought armed just blow it because
all the [ __ ] army India and then even
that was four years ago yeah and even
till now if I have butter I'm alright
with like I cook with bar all the time
but I'm alright with but fam
if I have ice cream I get blow it as
[ __ ] and I'm poor because I'm poppin
it's done I know what you mean bro you
no II mean and it's like raw but did you
know I'm black people are more
susceptible to being lactose intolerant
oh no I didn't know that and it's
because it simply is might as well is
simply just because in Africa there's
people don't drink milk like that
Asian people almost sit as well because
they just don't drink milk like that
he's Europeans that I've been drinking
milk for centuries okay then now that
their kids are not lactose intolerant so
it's just most of what I'm looking for
is not evolution but it's similar to
evolution but yeah just ancestry
this is this is definitely for you I'm
very good would you rather ooh I've got
a good road driver but not for this
episode I do in a different way but go
on
would you rather fight one horse one
horse-sized goose or yeah I'm good the
other one geese sized horses one horse
so one goose the size that are fighting
horse or hundred horses the size of
geese hundred hundred horses hundred
hundred horses hands I'm not touching a
goose horse sized or any other I'm not
touching a [ __ ] goose the size of
whatever fam especially a [ __ ] [ __ ]
was a huge never institute as they are
keys key some massive firm I would rub
much rather fight the horses I'll fight
them to the death they can Trump I don't
care I'm not firing that goose hundred
they terrify me they hiss have you seen
their teeth no and their beak is not
even teeth but obviously got beak and
they've got like this weird [ __ ] like it
looks like fur but it's like sharp in
there it looks like teeth but like furry
and sharp big teeth I'm not doing it
what cats are gonna think I'm not doing
it I'm not touching it I will scream -
no we put in the even thing you know I
realize so for context of people that
don't enter our mandem group chat
our group trap pops off so we've talked
about attack on Titan the other day so
it's an anime about these huge beings
and their Giants and they just eat
people on a ship we're talking about
that and if you just bumped into one if
you just saw one in [ __ ] covered in
commentary in a random street in
Coventry and when you said look I don't
think you understand like every civilian
will get last I pictured it in my head
and I was crying I can I manage your
panic and you sacrifice anyone any
enough any a man woman or child you will
sacrifice them to save yourself you're
the funniest [ __ ] guy when it comes
to fear of death you the funniest guy I
love my life by fear death so much you
do fit there I feared have so much I
wanna live bro that's just the be-all
and end-all I want to live I want to
[ __ ] live let me live that's all I
want them oh my god you do anything to
survive bro is so funny
go on nowadays the scenario I would suck
a dick to suck to live that's a scenario
to cure the world of Corona to cure the
world of corona virus you wouldn't suck
the dick but to save your own life 100%
you suck in yes fair enough
yes I think one thing is anyone would
suck a dick save their life as well it's
not register I think anyone would I
would like to think so
everyone would if they wouldn't what's
wrong with them I also bet it's to save
my life bro imagine right so the guy
says come walks in when is it enough for
now this is the thing when is enough
enough so tell me so a man walks in yeah
move his bredrin
put a gun to your [ __ ] head yeah and
says suck off my boy till he nuts yeah
and you will live or oh don't suck I'm
gonna shoot you right now so you're like
[ __ ] you know and then you suck him off
he nuts you wipe your mouth when you
just spit out you know whatever man and
then you think at least I get to live so
he pulls the gun away like unclicks
it's cool well done as soon as you stand
up another one of his boys walks in same
again son with my boy and he doesn't
even he doesn't even acknowledge that
you've sucked the first one he says the
exact same tone the exact same way again
repeat get on your knees
suck my boy often you know so I'm gonna
[ __ ] shoot you right now and you're
right so you get down suck off his next
man he nuts guy walks out pulls the gun
out spit out
you stand up same thing again third man
same tone hasn't acknowledged the first
two getting your [ __ ] knees on my boy
or I'm gonna shoot you right [ __ ] now
when's to the point where you're like
what's going on well first of all what's
going on here so you say so you say what
the what the [ __ ] is going on I've been
sucking three days I've been how many
bridges do you have and then he butts
you in your head that's the stop asking
[ __ ] questions I asked the question
it stopped asking [ __ ] questions
summer boy for you if you don't want to
die so you suck the next one off when's
the point that you just say [ __ ] you
shoot me when's the point how many dicks
do you think you need to be in before
you're just like I'm not sucking I think
I know I'll do go I think after the
first one obviously and the second one
happens I'd have to suck the second one
yeah obviously because I'm confused now
when the first one is shell-shocked
yeah half through his fear the second
one is more confusion so you have to
still have to do it yeah you don't want
to die hmm wait I don't think you'd
reaches purely because if he's doing
like you said exact same turnings that
same thing it's that same gesture as
soon as I've finished with the second
guy my thought process is this problem
this [ __ ] probably got another
guy waiting so what I would do is I
would either not even bother like
cleaning up I would have a door out the
room after he's done or fight the
beretta with a gun cool
that's what I would do and if I died oh
you'd risk the life yeah all right a
second one we came out for the second
one like I said it couldn't be after
this first cuz I assumed I was gonna go
free often yeah yeah
fair play fair play what about you I
don't know G thing is
I'd like to think I like to think I'm
brave yeah I like to think I'm brave in
the face of death but it's room reality
hits I don't know how many dicks I'm
sucking before because I'd like to I
think from this fund the first one i'm
saucin the sitch yeah fussing obsessed
in like kind of fight him can I take the
gun kind of run yeah all these things
but I don't know how many if it's the
same thing I I can imagine
I can imagine me being like right I know
he's got another boy I know he's got
another boy calm yes as soon as I
finished this one um
I'm fired him yeah and then I finish up
and then I'm thinking after the next one
I'm definitely and then I'm alright this
is the one this is the one and then you
look back I see him is like hmm after
the next one I'm definitely fighting
cause I could be there seven eight nine
decks I don't know
and by then my knees are cramping up I'm
sort of thinking of always my horse
killing me my eyes are just covered in
[ __ ] I don't think can I even can I have
even got the strength even got the
strength anymore because you know if you
fight him off there's a seven think
you're dying because you've got no way
I'm knocking I'm not good I'm simply not
good I kinda suck dicks all night
somebody's gonna give something has to
give I can't do this anymore
oh I'd call you suck dick after dick
after dick that's funny I refuse oh
jesus wept but then again if I haven't
got the energy what am I gonna do
you're gonna die there oh ha you're
actually gonna die now but the thing is
as well then it double backs and itself
or it doubles down and you're like you
like I would in I'll be two mindsets of
a rather die than suck a 15th dick
because I'm not doing this anymore but
that I've decided to be like bro you've
sucked 15 now you can't stop now
not because of sucky mix but you can't
go you're gonna die anyway you should
have died off for the first one yeah
there's no way in hell I'm dying after
15 no way in hell am i dying off of this
15th [ __ ] because I was finding out
someone's find the now imagine you they
found I imagine if I found out that I
said 15 dicks I wouldn't have this part
I went now to approach you I don't know
if you'd laugh at me or feel sorry from
your both o both for sure I would
definitely luck no I feel like if you
explained the scenario obviously I'll be
shell-shocked about the gun thing I'll
be [ __ ] shell-shocked but the fact
that you've sucked 16 dicks I mean all
night in your mouth I mean why don't you
why don't you just taught yourself
because bro gotta live your life like
that now he's mad he's mad because I was
watching similar not a similar thing but
no I was watching the Jeffrey Epstein
doc watch on Netflix yesterday and I
watched the first episode but all it was
was story after story off these young
girls he would invite them back to the
yard and they'd be like give me a
massage and from the massage would
either escalate as I announced or we
wouldn't it paid him to [ __ ] off
afterwards but escalate or not yeah and
there was one girl I hate to laugh cuz
it's not funny but it was one girl they
came to her she's a woman now she was I
hear so this is my story obviously the
first time I met Jeffrey I was with my
friend I was 14 years old and 14 they
were bare young all of their [ __ ] and
she was I was 14 years old knee right
and my friend said they were gonna go
massage some old guy and he's gonna pay
us and if I want to make some money
first of all she did not inquire enough
because if you hollowed me in class and
said fraud you want to make some money
they were inclined to be fair you want
me in class and said you wanna make some
extra money I was like gang how much
yeah and you'll I don't know like two
three hundred for like half an hour and
I'm like fam yes what do I have to do
well you just gotta massage some old
lady
I have so many questions so many
questions how much he had any questions
cuz she was I was like okay that's weird
but alright gullible who who and why
well anyway she went to his yard
massaged in the friend left her there
the friend said I needed to balance left
her there
so JYP's Jeffery Epps he made her get
starkers massaged him then she got
dressed and dipped and then I was like
the hotel mom I just read that straight
initials are so scared I didn't know
what to do
I wanted to run but same time he's gonna
kill me like I don't know this is the
weirdest situation I've ever been in
let's get it over with
it was so inappropriate I was so scared
all this stuff and I was I wrong and she
was that at the end of money I just took
I took the money and [ __ ] left and I
was like Fairplay and then next thing
she was like so yeah that went on for
about 3 or 4 years and then I was like
what what happened between you 1 in year
4 what do you mean you were so scared
you didn't know if you were gonna die
and it happened for 4 years you were 18
before you said enough is enough because
they're not sergeant you anymore Jeff
because it's not like she lived in the
yard she had to go to the other he
didn't keep her in a basement
she was so living her normal life
everyday but she did it for 4 years and
I was like at what point do you no
longer a victim she deserved it bro
she's after year 1 she laughed at the
first instance bro enough is enough
he's clearly not gonna kill you he just
likes little girls
he loved little girls there was bear any
stories so I need to watch it yeah but
yeah anyway that's what it reminded me
of of the dick sucking just like she did
it for four years and he must have done
more than get massage in four years he
must son more than again massage he hit
that seventeen seventeen eight eighteen
eighteen they were [ __ ] body when she
said it's illegal at sixteen and I
cannot no eighteen eighteen oh well I
think you're very safe state your 16
here sixteen here yeah sixteen in
America I think it's somewhere some
states at sixteen seventeen eighteen it
will vary state to state but Jesus three
or four years cuz I was not expecting
you to say that
fam I wasn't expected to hear it I'm
speaking this [ __ ] how much you pay no
subpoena talk imagine she's not victim
anymore and they said like whatever name
is Clarice Reese wherever any under
sources survivor she's not a survivor
fam she was that was her hustle that was
a psycho so that was a job she she
shoulda said I was employed by Jeffrey
for four years he would pay me X amount
to either suck him off massaging wank
him off wherever I was a kid time she
the way she described the first story I
was a sign no I was thinking I would
have been terrified yeah the whole time
I'm thinking party you stinking now you
just run yeah but you think you're nah
because the way she's describing it like
her I didn't know what was gonna happen
and when an adult tells a kid do this
and do that
you just do it yeah especially if it's
someone you don't know in a weird
[ __ ] mansion in Palm Beach and you're
[ __ ] massaging him a man was said she
was eight he just one time he just told
me to [ __ ] him grab his nipples as hard
as he could and squeeze them and she's
thinking I don't know what the [ __ ] to
do and he told me to get a snake and
stuff I was thinking boy if I was
fourteen I probably would've done it too
but I'll be terrified I would be [ __ ]
terrified and then she said no I did
that for four years I think she was
expecting everyone to be like oh my god
how did you survive that for four years
but I can you [ __ ] did you think you
were game you could have said no at any
time any time you were down you were
getting 200 a night so you would you a
game anyway I don't know how many dicks
burn are we don't let's do your money
also that's enough this was kind of
interest in a sort of for all right
let's have a look so am I the [ __ ]
for not wanting to hang out with a girl
my boyfriend is openly attracted to I'll
try to keep this one short it's long
breath that's all right I'm not gonna
read because I've already read it
basically so the synopsis is she her
boyfriend has a female friend that he
knew before his girlfriend okay
and before his girlfriend was his
girlfriend mm-hmm
they were just friends so whilst they
were just friends
he would openly say let's call it
Jessica
Jessica's so hot Jessica's boyfriend is
punching like she's barf she's Buffy but
so and then they got together mm-hmm my
man and he's current girlfriend now my
my name is going good and he's still
obviously Bertrand's with Jessica yeah
and she's met Jessica and she's friends
with Jessica yeah um but now every time
he mentions Jessica or he hangs out with
Jessica she's just flat-out livid and
the other day so fast forward to today
he invited them to go on a hike he
invited that also yeah and Jessica as a
man so first of all today he invited
Jessica and her man on a hike and
swimming in the lake with us maybe I'm
being crazy I basically told him he can
go but I'm not coming because it would
just be him staring at her the whole
time
quantum complimenting her and me feeling
like an ugly fat whale he told me he
told me I'm a crazy selfish [ __ ] and
I'm ruining his friendship am either
[ __ ] for not wanted to hang out with
him first and foremost the fact that
he's set up to his goal is is you're
herself crazy selfish out [ __ ] [ __ ] I
thought about Escalade I wasn't there
but I feel like it escalated that went
from here say yeah like Jason I'm
insecure like your relationship with
Jessica I just feel like a whale you
[ __ ] know I fish so much [ __ ] huh
what that will take me aback if I was
just to take two steps back a number
like what my breathing power would
change cuz yeah boy hey that's that's a
lot that's a lot of defensive he's
defensive when it comes to Jessica you
need to need to take a break there's
some troops that haven't been told
mm-hmm but I think it's as well that's
where you go first actually is she the
[ __ ] it's tough because females
regardless of whatever you say to a
female whether
being she's beautiful blah blah they
will always be insecure about something
Oh hundred without a shadow of a doubt
oh sure them every single day of your
life they'll be insecure about something
hundred so if they categorically know
that there's another woman out there
that you fancied before huh oh god she's
not like a hundred percent no woman is
letting that go never in a million years
no woman is letting that he done [ __ ]
up from bring it up in the first place I
don't blame him cuz you can't you can't
see where your life's gonna be here but
yeah you know woman is letting that go
thing is she's not the answer it's mad
because it's not how far she feels
insecure because he was saying all these
things about how much he loved but now
they're in a relationship and if he's
actually honest and true mmm his new
relationship with her could overshadow
anything he has to do with Jessica what
we should do because of the illness and
these times the fact that he's with her
these times maybe he fancied her way
more than Jessica anyway but he weren't
just gonna sit there and be like oh
you're so hot you're this you're that
because obviously they were just
prejudiced yeah I didn't want to [ __ ] up
the flow I don't know but his reaction
he ruined the whole reaction was a bit
much it was a lot but also you said he
fancied Jessica for example prior to his
current girlfriend so I'm assuming he
didn't know his current girlfriend
whilst he was fancying Jessica
he's my assumption here were friends
were all friends before no he knew
Jessica as his own friend
yeah that's I'm saying but they cut the
new girlfriend now didn't know they
didn't know each other when the my man
and Jessica were friends and when he
fancied Jessica the new girlfriend at
that time didn't know that they were
friends that she they weren't part of
the equation she wasn't by the equation
does that make sense no let me explain
okay let's say for example let's say
it's let's say I fancy I fancy you go my
current girlfriend now has never met
this girl up until we were together do
you know I mean so you're friends of the
go and you fancy her yeah
you're friends with this girl who later
on becomes your girlfriend yes and then
then she so now that is your girlfriend
now that she's my girlfriend in that
story did the gulp did my current
girlfriend or was my current girlfriend
already aware of the fact that they were
prejudiced before yes so whilst you were
bread rinse with your girlfriend so
before she was your girlfriend you were
just friends of her ok and you were also
just friends with Jessica so Belgium but
they didn't know each other but they
knew of each other through you so you
would talk to Jessica about a hmm and
you would talk to a about Jessica okay
they weren't friends but now you're
together with a now she's met Jessica
okay talk about you cuz I was gonna say
why in the hell would he even bring that
up to his new girlfriend that's what
that's my question I say yeah but when
yeah when they were just bread rains he
would just talk about her in passing so
oh she's with this guy my friend Jessica
is with this guy and he's partying and I
that's what makes it worse because now
that I know that it makes it worse
because that then stems to a girl that
she will now think she's second best
because throughout hid their whole
friendship yeah just thought you wanted
Jessica [ __ ] about a I've wanted Jessica
yes your substitute in her eyes that's
how she would see it regardless of
whatever you say hmm that's how she's
all with deep down she's gonna see like
that so I don't feel like she's
necessarily the Asaf I'm not going I
just feel like they should have he
should have known how I'm talking I'm
talking as if in the bread enough I
should have known how my current
girlfriend feels about the Jessica
situation regardless I should empathize
with that so that being said I should
never have even done that like invited
these men to the lake or whatever should
never have invited them considering I
know how my current girlfriend feels
about what I feel about why I used to
feel about Jessica also though this is
the thing so on the flip side yeah
does your girlfriend because you you
used to want Jessica now you're in your
relationship are you now just because
you said that mmm are you now supposed
to not be friends with Jessica anymore
that's also tough because I think
ultimately that's what my current
girlfriend one that's what she wants
yeah you're just gonna resent her if
that's what's gonna and maybe because
the fact is he invited Jessica and her
man in here so you didn't just say I'll
[ __ ] your man off like [ __ ] he said me
and my girlfriend you and your boyfriend
that's all do a ting so maybe he's maybe
he's trying a thing like broth obviously
why felt is the passive do be my bridge
bridge mean I like I'll bring my she can
bring her man I'll bring my girlfriend
oh he's a formatting and now you're
ahead telling me that you weigh in
comment and then maybe me over his
reaction is not warranted cars but maybe
Susie's selfish [ __ ] maybe his reaction
was do you know how much of a [ __ ]
I'm gonna be having to explain why
you're not coming mmm all like is this
what's gonna be forever now maybe he's
thinking okay so you will not come in
because I'm gonna be staring at Jessica
washes with her man and I'm with you so
how am I supposed to ever be friends
with Jessica now because you've
categorically told me you're not coming
to if you're not coming to this you'll
never come back never the air with the
her Mazda or not so what am I supposed
to do now
I you know what's so funny Gina was so
funny you're getting so I'm invested now
now now you see why he's called our
crazy self you know you're looking crazy
he was type in this cuz it started off
so light dude is he started typing this
[ __ ] crazy selfish [ __ ] crazy
selfish [ __ ] [ __ ] what am I supposed
to do now you're invested ayat because
reason it is thinking wrong that
Escalade yeah you're actually saying out
loud I understand why you said it now
that's jokes
yeah it's mass jokes I'd say my my end
in thesis is that she's not the [ __ ]
because she can't help how you feel yeah
but
she needs to understand the implications
of look a certain obvious ly certain
times you just firm [ __ ] for your
partner yeah you might not be happy
about it yeah but certain things - yeah
a lot of things are bigger than you yeah
and you're feeling certain things are
more important than you and your
feelings in this moment and that might
have been one of those times where it's
like shut up confirm it as my girlfriend
because if you don't it's gonna cause a
situation that's way bigger than if you
just did do you know I mean um but I
don't know I'd say she's not an [ __ ]
because she can't help how she feels
yeah
but same time she might be [ __ ]
sucking that big tongue that makes sense
I agree okay I don't I generally don't
think she's he also because she's
entitled to feel that way considering
he's been bragging on about it for years
so that can't be helped
insecurity you know hundreds was a huge
insecurity he shouldn't have [ __ ]
said it but whilst you were in that
scenario are we in the hot seat
understand why he said because it was a
tip of your I'm crazy I'm crazy it was
on a tip of your tongue I live in a
dream I'm sometimes I'm so sir that I
live in a [ __ ] dream because I can
get into this and you can imagine yeah
and all of a sudden I'm here I didn't
even know where does like I don't know
his name I'm him and you're saying
you're seeing him through me that
doesn't make any sense that's psycho
behavior um yeah man let's rap out let's
see you guys